what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so I am going to err on the side of
caution and assume that there's going to
be some kind of huge dump with regards
to like the Punisher on the Netflix
series and assuming that there is we are
going to be a little bit dangerous
really for the first time on my youtube
channel we're going to try our hand at
Punisher max now here's the deal
in Marvel Comics back before all-new
all-different marvel for those of you
guys who were new to it all Marvel had
basically two publishing initiatives the
first was everything in Marvel Comics
that was not Marvel max and so it was
the ultimate universe and the what-if
stories and the main Marvel Universe
were you know Steve Rogers was Captain
America so on and so forth then you had
Punisher Max and while Marvel said The
Punisher max was really geared towards
like adult readers it wasn't always I
mean Punisher max was about as dark as
at God but even Jessica Jones originated
in an Marvel Maxo that whole thing with
a purple man all that kind of stuff that
was all Marvel max because it was really
the only way you could get away with
that kind of storytelling but Punisher
max was like the definitive run of the
Punisher character of Frank Castle
because his character was so violent and
so gruesome that you couldn't really do
his character justice by throwing him in
the main Marvel Universe and so the best
way to think of Punisher max is that
this is basically what the Punisher is
doing or what he was doing
when he wasn't alongside the other
superheroes so it's really just kind of
his own solo series essentially it's
just a much darker and a much grittier
take on the whole thing now assuming
that you know this gets a reasonable
reception and we actually end up doing
The Punisher max storyline by Garth
Ennis then we'll go a little bit more
into that but what this is is basically
the definitive origin of how Frank
Castle became The Punisher and that's
one of the coolest things about this
because historically speaking it's
always been the general idea that like
the death of Maria and the children of
Frank Castle is what set him on the road
to becoming the Punisher what Punisher
Bourne does is it actually tells us the
Frank Castle was well on his way to
becoming the Punisher long before his
wife and children were killed that was
just the event that broke the camel's
back that was the straw that set him on
the path of becoming the villain did we
all know and love and has been played
spectacularly by Jon Bernthal man I
can't think of a better guy to play The
Punisher than Jon Bernthal if you ever
happen to see this man I hope man i hope
you know what you're getting into
because you are the pleasure now
you are Frank castle but nonetheless so
the cool thing about this is that
remember Frank Castle at least this
story anyway picks up with the Vietnam
War as far as I'm aware it was not an
established fact that Frank Castle
aspired to be Captain America until the
events of Civil War and it was actually
an offhand comment that I believe was
made by Sam Wilson when the Punisher
just showed up and shot a whole bunch of
villains during the Civil War storyline
and so on and so forth but it was a
statement made by Sam Wilson the Frank
Castle idolized Captain America Steve
Rogers he wanted to be like him the
difference is that Frank Castle was born
in a different era the goal was that he
could basically be just like Steve
Rogers he could be the guy on the
frontlines leading the fight leading the
charge all that kind of good stuff now
where that was civil war and that was
the main Marvel Universe which was far
less gritty the Marvel max line is a lot
more gritty and it's a lot more ruthless
in terms of how this is done now I'm not
an expert by any standard of measurement
on the Vietnam War but what I do know at
least from what I've gathered from the
research that I've done this story
basically picks up with the notion of
the NVA the North Vietnamese Army and
the Vietcong as far as I'm aware from
the investigation that I've done and
those people who are more familiar with
Vietnam history with the Vietnam War can
probably correct me but the North
Vietnamese Army was basically the
Communist military front of the North
Vietnamese forces the Vietcong were
basically guerrilla warfare soldiers I
could be wrong but I'm pretty sure
that's the case but the factor names
here that went Frank Castle this entire
story is actually told from the
perspective of a guy named Stevie
Goodwin and what he does here is he
basically focuses on Frank castle as he
exists in this particular scenario the
Frank Castle is essentially the
second-in-command on this base he's a
guy who's basically directly under the
guy running the show and the idea is
that he takes his forces out you know
all the time to go on these routine
patrols different things like that but
where other individuals just want to go
back home or where they want to get out
of the Vietnam War Captain Frank Castle
lives for battle he lives for conflict
and so while he's out going on these
patrols well he doesn't have like a hero
complex where he's not like rushing his
guys into suicide runs different things
like that instead he's hoping that it
will all lead to like this great big
huge massive battle and these things
that unfold this is also introduced with
the notion of them basically shooting up
what appears to be a caravan now
remember when it came to the Vietnam War
again I'm just kind of speaking with
with research here the Vietcong what
made them so dangerous is that if you
saw a guy walking down the road and he
looked like he had a pack mule and it
looked like he was just a guy who was
selling goods you didn't know if that
pack mule was loaded with clothes and
resources and so on and so forth or if
that pack dealer was loaded with weapons
and bombs that he was just going to
start throwing at you as one of the
things that made the guerrilla warfare
tactics in a Vietnam war so dangerous is
because you couldn't really spot the
enemy that readily and so because of
that the initial you know response here
by Frank castle and his guys is to just
shoot these forces all the pieces now of
course it's ended up turning out to be
you know members of the Vietcong but the
fact remains here that is basically just
this display of the fact of how gruesome
things are the Frank Castle takes no
prisoners if he sees an enemy or what he
believes to be an enemy they immediately
die on sight now again the perspective
of Stevie Goodwin here is that he looks
at these circumstances any sense Frank
Castle doesn't care if he lives or dies
here I mean I guess you know he cares
about living so long as you can continue
to fight the next battle but when the
war is over the purpose behind his life
is going to be over and so in that
moment
Stevie Goodwin looks to the future and
says this is not going to be the end of
his life that he's going to have a wife
he's going to have kids there were
things like that and so again this
really hits home at the idea of how the
Vietnam War impacted different people
there were some who turned to drugs
there were some who turned to violence
there were some who just lost themselves
in their entirety and there were some
who didn't have any real effect at all
but it was a war that really impacted a
multitude of different men and women in
a multitude of different ways now the
other half of this is the kernel the guy
basically running the show here and this
guy is effectively just a drunk I mean
he's essentially just given up and
that's really the state of the entire
base here in Cambodia at Valley Forge
more or less but it's essentially just
Frank Castle doing the best you can to
hold things together while at the same
time being overcome by its lust for
battle and the kernel just you know just
kind of having given up now this leads
to the arrival of a general and this is
really one of the most important parts
of the story and the reason for this is
because of the fact that this general
basically says why is it that displaced
this this hellhole more or less is just
a void of anything symbolizing military
standards it is to say people who salute
to their superiors people who keep the
entire base clean who keep things in
check why is it this place really exists
more like a frat house than an actual
military base and of course
response to Frank Castle here is that
the entire place is basically on its
last legs and this is when we find out
this is basically at a point when the
war is beginning to wrap up remember
when it came to the Vietnam conflict
once we basically ended up having the
Pentagon Papers released and the idea
that the Vietnam conflict was not
America run rushing in for the sake of
being altruistic and doing the right
thing but it was a battle of resources
it was a battle of intentions it was a
war that was engaged in for a particular
agenda in a particular set of events but
span the course of some three or four
presidencies then that immediately led
to the American people who had already
hated the war protesting even further
and so once it got to the point where
there was a legitimate incredible threat
to existing seats for senators and
existing seats for president and
existing seats for congressmen and
Congresswomen the political stance on
the Vietnam War began to shift and it
became really more of a political war
being swept under the rug and over the
course of the existence of American
involvement but the fact remains here
that this is basically led to a
circumstance whereby the u.s. is
essentially pulling out and so the
arrival here this general showing up at
you know Valley Forge is is on for the
purpose of analyzing whether or not it's
even worth keeping it open and if it is
worth keeping it open is it going to
have the kind of resources that are
necessary in order to maintain a long
haul if it's not worth keeping open then
the question is why as the idea is a
Frank Castle is basically forced with
this scenario that he may lose the basis
behind his existence here he end up
losing the reason for why it is he's
here in the first place he wants to
fight in this war he wants to keep
fighting in this war because he believes
that he can legitimately win it on his
own as though the result is that he
actually leads the general into the into
a line of fire of a sniper if he
basically tells us general hey look what
you're looking for in terms of why this
thing you know why this base needs to be
here is right over there just just go
over there go you know peek your head
out take a look and you'll see what
we're talking about as soon as he steps
up the generals heads blown off now the
funny thing about this is a frank castle
was actually blocking a sign that said
danger sniper at work dawn to dusk and
so because of the fact that the General
Assembly wasn't paying any attention
because he wasn't looking around he ends
up being a victim of this of the sniper
but what this does is it shows us the
lengths that Frank castle is willing to
go to in order to make sure that he's
still able to do the kind of things that
he wants to do to continue this battle
now for the most part this is just Frank
castle being Frank Castle this is him
just kind of swept up in the idea that
he can legitimately win the Vietnam War
by
self in terms of frank castle tumbling
down this rabbit hole and eventually
becoming the Punisher this begins to
take place when he begins hearing the
voice of some disembodied individual now
this is one of the crazy things here is
because the Garth Ennis gives it to us
in a way where it could be a number of
different things it could be Frank
Castle himself in the form of his
subconscious it could very well be the
devil himself there's no real
explanation on who this voice is in the
immediate instead it's just a voice
there but the voice basically mimics the
perspective of Frank castle and saying
that yes the general was trying to screw
you guys over you know you knew the war
was going to come to an end at some
point or another but the general was
trying to speed it up but with the
general being dead now the war can keep
going on now you can keep fighting now
you can beat a hero now you can do what
it is that you love and go into these
these investigations go into these
marches and so on and so forth that
continue the path of trying to win this
war on your own now the other side of
Frank Castle also comes to fruition when
Frank Castle on this this platoon of
sorts is led on one of their tracks and
of course they actually end up coming
across a sniper who manages to take out
a couple of people but Frank castle as
fearless as he is instead of backing off
picks up the m60 now for those of you
guys who have read Punisher max you
basically read the store the the story
arc in the beginning which picks up with
the idea of Frank Castle as part of as
part of Marvel max that m60 moment where
he just unloads there's this amazing
moment the beginning of the story he
runs into a building shoots a mob boss
and then runs outside and starts
counting down he's like you know five
seconds when they realized what it is
that happened and they're like three
seconds once they marshal their forces
and they're like one second when they
get outside and then once they're there
he just like Yanks off this giant clock
and there's this m60 to just start
spraying down all these soldiers it's
one of the coolest moments you know ever
in the history of a Punisher story I
absolutely love the way that it opens
but in fact your name tear in this
little tidbit instead of Frank Castle
cowering away instead of him kind of
running away he literally grabs the m60
and just starts opening up on this
sniper and so what this does is it
basically brings in the idea that Frank
Castle is a man without fear but that's
one of the most dangerous things about
this is because in this particular
scenario the way the story is being
written by by Garth Ennis and the way
that Frank castle is perceived by Stevie
Goodwin and the other members of this
platoon is it a
and who has no fear is a man that's not
afraid of losing anything and a man
who's not afraid of losing anything is a
man that has nothing to lose and so in
the end it's not as Oh Frank Castle
looks around and says all man the may
end up losing my platoon instead Frank
Castle cares only for himself Frank
Castle cares only for making sure that
he can continue this war and if it means
that all the other members of the
platoon are killed then that's just the
way it goes and so that's what makes it
so dangerous is because Frank Castle
doesn't have their backs and none of
them can trust him but the problem is
that they're all dealing with a Vietnam
War in their own way now this is where
the story begins to get really into the
vein of Marvel match and the reason why
is because of the fact that while they
are able to take out one of these
snipers and while she does try to keep
you know trying to kill herself
ultimately in the absence of Frank
Castle some of the members of a platoon
attempt to rape her and that's one of
the huge things about this when it comes
to Punisher max Garth Ennis does not shy
away from anything if you've read
Punisher max the slavers arc is a
perfect example of that it is an arc
that deals with human trafficking and
Frank Castle man Frank Castle let them
have it it is it's I've never seen
anything like that in account before and
it's absolutely mind-blowing the way
that it's written it's beautifully done
but it's crazy the way to this all
depict it but the idea here is that once
Frank Castle arrives on the scene he
realizes that this platoon is engaging
you know in this this heinous act and
this is the moral principle of Frank
Castle despite that dr. Frank Castle
doesn't care despite the fact that he
has no problems killing anybody he
considers to be an enemy there is still
a kind of line that they don't cross and
that's the irony to all this is because
this is the one thing about Frank Castle
that never changes the one thing about
Frank Castle that never goes away fairy
castle always okay with killing the
enemy
he's never okay with killing the good
guys Frank Castle believes in punishment
he believes that people who do bad
things deserve to die the instant that a
man breaks into another man's house he
sacrificed his right to life whether he
knew it or not is irrelevant the fact
remains that's the price he's going to
pay that pleading ignorance is no excuse
for committing such a heinous act that's
the life of a castle that's how he views
the world that's how he does thinks what
this does is it tells us the despite
Frank Castle being such a antihero such
a terrible human being in a lot of
different ways there's some lines that
you just don't cross and so that's one
of the coolest things about this is
because what ends up happening is of
course he basically shoots this woman
and arguing that it was going to be the
end of her I mean no matter what
happened you know even if you were to
force all the soldiers off of her and
she were to be handed over to the US
military you know there would have been
guys out there groups out there that
would have had their way with her while
they were trying to interrogate her if
she wasn't able to provide the
information that they wanted then they
would have killed her her life up until
the point that she died would have been
one of absolute misery and absolute
horror a terrible situation to be in and
so asuma just killed her that way is to
basically spare her a miserable
existence but not only that because of
the fact that one of the members of his
platoon had tried to rape a woman Frank
Castle in turn drowns him and that's why
this is so big is because again it's
this moral standard the Frank castle has
now of course DB Goodwin sees the entire
set of events unfold but it's the moral
compass that Frank castle has there are
lines that you don't cross and that's
why Punisher match is so cool is because
unlike the main Marvel Universe for the
Punisher has fought Ghost Rider and what
a Punisher is fought spider-man and what
a Punisher has fought the Avengers
single-handedly in one it's this story
this this line of events that crop up
and it basically says yeah but like the
Punisher has a moral compass he has a
viewpoint if you are a superhero and you
do something that the Punisher considers
to be an evil act he will find you and
he will kill you that's what he does
that's his role in the world and if he
doesn't kill you he will die trying
whether it's a friend whether it's an
ally whether it's a brother or a sister
there's no gray area and the world of
Frank Castle there's black and there's
white hence the reason why there's a
really great story arc black is wide
enough is down it's just one of the
coolest things there's this amazing
monologue that he has let me let me sigh
Shaq here for a second to give you guys
some perspective about about Punisher
max there's this amazing monologue that
Punisher has - where he goes in and he's
clearing out this this house with all
these drug dealers and criminals and so
on and like as he's going through he
starts talking about this dream that he
has and in this dream he doesn't stop
what he doesn't stop at the criminals he
doesn't stop at like the drug dealers
and the crooked politicians and so on
and so forth he kills everybody kills
every single person that he considers to
be a bad guy and then he looks at
society he says you elected those
corrupted you know politicians you allow
people to steal from others
you watched muggings and rapes and
different things like that happen and
chose not to report anything you are as
bad as the villains that I'm facing and
then in turn Frank Castle goes to turn
his guns on the average person and then
wakes up right before he pulls the
trigger it's just this amazing monologue
daddy that he does it's one of the
coolest things little moments like that
are what make the stories so cool but
the fact remains here the idea of him
moving on the road of becoming the
Punisher is when the Punisher fooled
Stevie Messiah and says why didn't you
speak up when you saw me drowning that
guy and a for Stevie's whole idea is
well you know I was terrified but why
did you do that and upon it you know
Frank Castle simply says because I
wanted to punish him because he deserved
punishment for his actions and so again
that's what makes this such a hallmark
thing is because this is Frank Castle
becoming the Punisher this is Frank
Castle becoming the character that we've
all come to realize is a guy who has no
gray area in his moral viewpoint it's
black and it's white you're a good guy
or bad guy you know it's one of those
crazy things about his character but the
fact remains that with Frank Castle in a
position where he actually has the
ability or at least you know kind of
toys with the notion of killing the
colonel ultimately he ends up backing
out on this particular role and instead
he really begins to marshal his forces
towards the idea of essentially the
Vietcong forces and the North Vietnamese
Army launching this final attack against
the Valley Forge retreat now the reason
why this is kind of interesting is
because Frank Castle has no reason to
believe this is absolutely true instead
he's just kind of running on a gut
instinct but the gut instinct turns out
to be accurate when there's illumination
in the middle of a firefight and we
actually end up seeing just hundreds of
these soldiers descending on on Frank
castles platoon and so of course
grabbing the m60 and immediately just
spraying away it's an absolute bloodbath
and this is really where Frank hassel
breaks I mean this is the moment right
here this is the moment where he
switches over from being Frank castle to
being the Punisher and this comes in the
form of the fact that his guys are
running low on ammo his guys are running
low on resources you know it's a war of
attrition they're out man they're
outgunned they cannot last forever and
so what ends up happening here is that
where the colonel essentially shoots
himself so he doesn't have to deal with
this particular onslaught and Frank
castle is the one guy who's basically
left alive or at least seems to be the
one guy who's basically left alive in
the face of Stevie Goodwin basically
being killed off
voice begins to ring into the mind of
Frank Castle and it's such a great
moment because the boy says I know that
you want to live Frank Castle I know
that you love blood I know you love
death I know that you believe that there
are bad people out there who need to be
punished
I can make that happen for you Frank I
can give you the strength to kill the
bad guy I can give you the strength to
engage in this battle that will go on
forever and ever and ever and ever
all you have to do is just say yes all
you have to do is hand yourself over
Frank and if you do that Frank I will
give you everything you need to survive
the night and Frank Castle hands himself
over now we don't actually see the
particular firefight when Frank Castle
loses his mind
instead we pick up the morning after and
Frank Castle single-handedly killed
every single one of these guys who had
descended on the base now the
implication here is that somewhere along
the line he ran out of ammunition and he
basically just started using the butt
end of an m16 and bashing people's
brains in but we're also kind of showing
here at least what seems to be taking
place here is a Frank Castle just kind
of gave in to his inner devil he gave in
to his inner demon lost himself in the
fray of all this and that's what makes
this so cool that's why I say this is
the moment that Frank Castle snaps
because he crosses a line that he can't
come back from and so as the sole
survivor of this massive attack when
he's brought back home he's hailed to be
a hero the problem with this is that
when he left Vietnam Frank Castle
believed that he had left that life
behind and instead he didn't as soon as
he's with his family as soon as he's
back with the people that he cares about
that voice starts ringing home that
voice starts cropping up and saying
things like I've been at this a lot
longer than you have Frank Castle I've
been doing this for a lot longer than
you and I told you when you handed
yourself over to me there would be
payment payment would come due I would
come knocking on your door and now is
the time for you to pay the price what
this does is it basically shines this
perspective in saying that the Punishers
family the death of his wife Gloria the
death of his kids does not how he became
the Punisher he became the Punisher a
long time before that
they simply just gave him a reason to
adopt a name their death gave him
motivation it gave him Drive and it gave
him a reason to go on this massive
killing spree attacking every single
villain that he came across no matter
where they
anywhere in the world but when a being
said guys punisher max punisher boy this
is extremely tame in comparison to like
the rest of the punisher max line i mean
after this things get i mean like with
the main punisher story things get
really violent really fast but it is a
really really cool story it's extremely
well done the way that it all comes
together but anyway guys we're going to
go ahead and bring this video to an end
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
enjoy